is called to order
Lord
agenda for this meeting
and security of Ukraine
the agenda is adopted
conformation
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
Ness
in this meeting
it is so decided
of the European Union
item two of the agenda
I now give the floor to Mr Martin
Griffiths
Madam president thank you very much
indeed and I'm speaking to you from
from Geneva
when I last spoke to the council about
the situation in Ukraine in March
I highlighted then the humanitarian
impact of the full-scale war not only on
the people of Ukraine
and on The Wider World already
struggling with a myriad of shocks
in that context at that time
I emphasize the overwhelming need
for a political solution to the war on
Ukraine and indeed peace to be returned
to its people
and I know with regret therefore shared
I'm sure by all in this Council that
hostilities including missile strikes
currently appear
to be escalating on both sides of the
front line
Air Raid Sirens continue to ring out in
cities and towns across Ukraine
civilians continue to seek protection
from bunkers some for days on end
and as Ukraine emerges
from a hard winter
civilian casualties are rising to their
highest levels in months
High commission for human rights is now
verified
a staggering 23 600 civilian casualties
since February 2022
and we all know perfectly well that the
actual toll is likely to be very much
higher than that
humanitarian impacts are extensive
as those of us who have had the awful
privilege to visit Ukraine has seen
firsthand
many communities along the northeastern
border with the Russian Federation and
near the front line are encircled
cut off from water food
and Medical Care by heavy ground
fighting and blocked roads
only last week in kerasan
where I visited some months back
residential buildings only last week a
school an outpatient hospital an elderly
care facility were reportedly damaged
leaving schools of civilians needing
shelter and health care
and missile strikes in Odessa
hit the humanitarian storage Warehouse
a Ukrainian Red Cross Mobile hospital
nikolaev was also it
humanitarian supplies
vital medical equipment
were destroyed
fortunately on those occasions no
humanitarian staff or volunteers were
injured but to threat to humanitarians
and civilians represented by the latest
Wailers attacks Madam president
is persistent
and of course I'm compelled once again
to record here to this Council
that under International humanitarian
law
parties must
must take constant care to protect all
civilians and civilian objects including
homes schools hospitals and other
essential infrastructure as well as
humanitarian facilities and assets
and even as though that law is breached
the essential quality of it must be a
reminder for all of us
and the president as you can see the
humanitarian operating environment
remains complex and dangerous
nonetheless thanks to the courage of
humanitarian workers
particularly and mostly local workers
United Nations and its partners
its National partners and its
International Partners continue to
deliver life-saving assistance to
Frontline areas and elsewhere across
Ukraine
nearly 3.6 million people
received humanitarian assistance in
Ukraine in the first quarter of this
year
this includes people receiving cash
assistance
receiving food health care and
libraryhood support
around 43
inter-agency convoys
have delivered supplies
in heroic moments
to around 280 000 people in front light
areas so far this year
this is a particular feature of the
humanitarian operation in Ukraine and I
want to pause there for one second to
pay tribute to those brave people who
take those convoys to where they need to
be
the partners who then take the
Commodities from those convoys
for the so-called last mile delivery
are always of course
National Partners Ukrainian
organizations and Ukrainian people
there are still limitations on our
ability by the president to deliberate
to all those in need
more is needed to take our efforts to
scale the biggest challenge Remains the
impediments to reaching all areas in
Donetsk Johansson
currently under the military control of
the Russian Federation
the humanitarian notification system
together with direct engagement with key
interlocutors in Moscow and Kiev
practice such as uh been encased since
the early days of this war
this was set up to maximize the
opportunity for save an unimpeded
passage of interagency convoys to those
areas however
despite 14 months of notifying the
partners of our intentions through this
system we have not been able to deliver
assistance to communities along the
front line in areas under the military
control of the Russian Federation
not once
access options to those areas therefore
including different modalities response
continue to be explored through
engagement with all parties
it is imperative that we do this that we
explore all options to reach civilians
wherever they are
as I've said before under International
humanitarian law all parties
must allow safe and rapid and unimpeded
passage of humanitarian relief civilian
for civilians in need and must ensure
that Personnel engaged in that work must
have the freedom of movement required
for that work
please I urge the parties
to reinforce and strengthen their
facilitation efforts so that we can do
that so that we can reach US Women's
Madam president
food exported under the Black Sea
initiative and food and fertilizer
exports from the Russian Federation
continued to make it crucial
contribution to food security at a
global level
more than 30 million metric tons of
cargo have now been safely exported from
Ukrainian reports under that initiative
a moment a quantity which was reached as
we were together in Istanbul discussing
the future of that initiative just the
other day
of this 30 million metric tons just over
600 000.
matric tons of wheat have been
transported by the world food program in
direct support of humanitarian
operations in Afghanistan Ethiopia Kenya
Somalia and Yemen places we often
discuss in this chamber
the latest FAO analysis indicates that
Global cereal prices have fallen by
close to 20 percent over the past 12
months last month International wheat
prices reached their lowest level since
July 2021 driven in part
in part by the continued movement of
Ukrainian grain by large quantities
available for export on the Russian
Federation and other other locations
this is undeniable progress of course
but much much more remains to be done
predictable supplies for humanitarian
food assistance operations continue to
be required
the initiative refers to the export of
ammonia
but this is still not yet been realized
over the past month we have also
unfortunately seen a reduction in the
volumes of exports moving out of
Ukraine's black seaports due to
challenging Dynamics within the joint
coordination Center set up by that
agreement of 22nd of July last year in
Istanbul and thus a related slowdown in
operations
in recent weeks and last week in
particular we have engaged in intensive
discussions with the parties to the
Black Sea initiative to secure agreement
on its extension and the improvements
needed for it to operate effectively and
predictably and these efforts will
continue and focus in the coming days
in parallel I paid tribute
to Rebecca Greenspan and her team under
Rebecca's leadership who have continued
to deliver a wide range of support with
concrete results under the memorandum of
understanding
between the United Nations and the
Russian Federation on the facilitation
of Russian food and fertilizer exports
so important for international Global
Food security
the reasons I have set out
I hope you would agree that continuation
in the backseat initiative is critically
important as is recommitment by the
parties to its smooth and efficient
operation
and we will continue to call on all to
meet their responsibilities as the world
watches us very closely
I want to particularly thank here Madam
president the government of turkey who
hosted our talks last week
who broken the deal who've hosted Us in
Istanbul we've intervened at all levels
at all times to make this deal
be sustained I thank them very very much
for their efforts their energy and their
commitment
it is clear
that the people of Ukraine
and millions around the world
illa Ford a continuation of this war
more than ever they need an end
hostilities the political solution to
end the conflict
and I am one of those who therefore
calls on the council
and all member states to support any
efforts that may bring about an end to
the Carnage and destruction we have seen
so clearly so vividly and so
continuously
in the meantime Madam president United
Nations
its humanitarian Partners remain
committed to safeguarding the life and
dignity of persons affected by War and
to the pursuit of peace
whether it be today tomorrow or in the
weeks to come
I thank you for this opportunity thank
you
I thank Mr Griffiths for his briefing
those members of the counselors to make
states
[Music]
to the representative of France
since the time
she could do
courageously in order to determine the
facts have also been exposed as we have
charges
and France
as well as through our support of the
United Nations
countless violations
and Russia is solely responsible
of some countries
foreign
of Ecuador
civilians have died and have been
wounded
foreign
services and again primarily impacts
women boys we are concerned
condolences to France
journalism as well we recognize the
significant role of reporters
foreign
[Music]
based on
preparations in accordance with
international law thank you
percentage of albanians thank you madam
I thank USG Griffiths for his update we
pay tribute to his efforts and work as
well as of the entire Ultra team to meet
the humanitarian needs in Ukraine and
elsewhere to alleviate the suffering of
people everywhere
colleagues after 16 months the special
Russian military aggression has stalled
on the ground
but it has not stopped and it has not
been less deadly
Beyond casualties and destruction along
the front lines missiles and illegally
acquired drones continue their deadly
attacks against innocent civilians their
homes and civilian infrastructure the
USG just shared a sobering account of
the latest escalations and their
consequences
international law prohibits aiming at
civilian buildings and nothing justifies
it if not to instigate fear
tyr helps authoritarian regimes to
impose total control over their people
and fear in Warfare is used to terrorize
civilians
but the truth is that after
446 days of Relentless War ukrainians
have not surrendered and all attempts to
terrorize them have just made them fight
back harder
after 10 months of grueling flight
assaults bakmud tells one of the key
stories of this episode War
if maripol became the ugly face of this
war and the symbol of brutality takmud
already a side of tragedy will be known
as the symbol of Ukrainian resistance
yet the painful reality is that more
than 23 000 civilians have been killed
or wounded
only during the first week of May ohthr
recorded 221 civilians
civilian casualties in Ukraine
Kremlin may keep saying that Russia is
not fighting the Ukrainian people
this does not even come close to a bad
joke
it is Ukrainian civilians that are dying
under the Russian bombs and shells those
14 million people uprooted from their
homes those 18 million requiring
Unitarian assistance and protection
unable to afford or access enough food
and the thousands of children
systematically abducted have one thing
in common they are all ukrainians
we know now that Russian troops have
tortured sexually abused and murdered
non-combatants in towns they have
occupied like in butcher also videos
have surfaced allegedly showing Russian
soldiers beheading Ukrainian prisoners
of War
colleagues since the beginning of this
war serious violations of human rights
and international emitter and law
committed in various regions of Ukraine
have been duly documented
the findings of the commission of
inquiry and of the oec Moscow mechanism
Point clearly to war crimes and crimes
against humanity
evidence will one day be presented to
the court of law for accountability
but among all the crimes committed in
Ukraine the most incomprehensible and
inhuman are those committed against
children
everywhere in every culture children are
associated with innocence and the need
for care and protection and crimes
against them are seen as particularly
revolting because they are
the forcible Mass deportation of
Ukrainian children to Russia disguised
under different false names or
initiatives is nothing less than a
re-education process in total denial of
children rights it is indefensible
we expect the yearly report of the
Secretary General and children Arab
conflicts to include the effects of
military regression Ukraine the military
aggression Ukraine has had on children
Madam president
this war continues to have implications
Beyond Ukraine especially for the global
food security
for hundreds of millions of people
around the world food on the table
depends also from the continuation and
the pace of the Black Sea grain
initiative
we are concerned about reports of
activity slowdown as the USG
told us the number of ships transporting
rain has been significantly reduced
lately and any renewal Beyond 18 of May
seems to go no longer in months but just
in weeks
we know what happens in the world when
food is weaponized prices go up there is
less food for vulnerable populations and
people go hungry
one does not sit in the security Council
to deny food to those in need
therefore we call for the initiative to
be extended as part of the global
humanitarian response in a way and for a
period to provide the necessary
assurances and confidence to markets and
people
modern president two days ago in Germany
president zielinski and the people of
Ukraine were awarded the international
Charlemagne prize of ahang for their
fight to defend their country but also
Europe and its values
the contrast could not be more striking
a leader defending its country and its
people fighting for Independence is
welcomed honored respected and revered
everywhere another one the author of the
worst security crisis in Europe for
decades is under arrest warrant by
International Justice
colleagues
there is never a bad time to stop a war
especially one that should not have
started
Russia must understand that it cannot
have its way in Ukraine and that it
cannot decide for its people and their
future
it looked far better
be to unconditionally completely and
immediately will draw from Ukraine
respect its internationally recognized
borders
until this is done and until reason has
prevailed we will continue to stand in
full solidarity with the government and
people of Ukraine in the defense of
their Nation their land and our shared
values
foreign
under Secretary General Martin Griffith
for his update
we commend him
and his team
for their Noble and tireless work
worldwide
I wish to acknowledge the presence in
this session
of his Excellency Department
representative of Ukraine
Madame President
according to the global humanitarian
overview
2023 published by orchard and I quote
this year
grinding conflict
the deadly climate crisis and health
epidemics
including cholera and covid-19
caused record levels of hunger and
displacement
wasn't poverty and put a quality for
women and girls
increasingly Out Of Reach
as a result
one out of every 23 people worldwide
now needs humanitarian relief
more than double the percentage
just four years ago
and of course
this is a bleak and terrible scenario
and it is heartbreaking to know that
conflicts
Remain the major driver of humanitarian
crisis
and more so
in Ukraine
the humanitarian action
is an imperative that aims
to better address the demands of those
in need
particularly in terms of protection and
assistance
Madam president
notwithstanding all existing
International legal framework
that govern the protection of civilians
including the humanitarian dimension
guaranteeing effective protection of
civilians in conflicts remains are
formidable challenge
it is our principle position that
humanitarian work must be given a high
priority
in this context
we call
on the parties in Ukraine
to take urgent measures
that can allow for an environment
conducive conditions for Aid
distribution
safeguards of a delivery
reconstruction and fostering
long-term peace and Reconciliation in
the country
we reiterate our urgent call for the
belligerent parties
to immediately return to direct
negotiations
conducted in good faith
We Believe
that peace initiatives put forward
by a number of states
including member states of this Council
should be given
a chance
political settlement
is the right way to address
humanitarian problems
in this context
we agree with the ECG Griffiths that the
Black Sea grain initiative
is critically important
we therefore call for the Black Sea
grain initiative
which is due to expire this week
to be renewed
improved
and expanded in line
with the findings of the secretary
General's Global crisis response group
on food
energy and finance and I thank you
president president
of the Russian Federation
foreign
[Music]
we received foreign
is not fighting the civilians and it's
not subjecting them to a targeted
strikes unlike the Ukrainian armed
forces
of civilians killed in Afghanistan Iraq
Libya and other countries
of sanctions against judges as was the
case with investigations
that they are now tired of justifying
every of theirs every one of their steps
[Music]
the chief of intelligence
the West has always
the Ukrainian leaders will not even be
able to take with them when they uh
Ukraine real Goods to the EU and not the
markets of developing States
went into the U.S country foreign
[Music]
last week
we can't guarantee that the package
agreement will be extended
president
sorry I thanked Mr Martin Griffiths for
his insight for a briefing it is with a
profound concern that we continue to
witness Russia's ongoing aggression
against Ukraine constituting a flagrant
violation of the international law
including the U.N Charter
Russia should stop the war they started
the world they started Japan denounces
Russia's attacks on civilian
infrastructure and urban centers across
Ukraine
the attacks on housing complexes
hospitals schools energy facilities and
other essential installations for Life
jeopardizes the Warfare and future of
the Ukrainian people
we once again recall that indiscriminate
attack on innocent civilian population
constitute the war crime there must be
no impunity for war crimes and other
acts of atrocities
Russia must be held accountable
we further condemn all violations of
international humanitarian law and human
rights abuses
urging all parties to the conflict to
uphold International humanitarian
principles
to restore just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine Japan is committed to the rapid
recovery and reconstruction of Ukraine
we will continue to steadily Implement
humanitarian financial and other systems
totaling 7.6 billion US dollars to
support Ukraine in various Fields
including electricity mine actions and
agriculture
Madam president
challenges we face today are very
complex but but Russia's aggression
against Ukraine has exacerbated the
global food security crisis and quote
high caused High inflation
to respond to this urgent issue the
Black Sea grain initiative has played a
pivotal role in mitigating the
repercussions on the world food supply
adaptively facilitated the export of
over 30 million metric tons of grain
from Ukraine ports allocating over 56
percent of these food exports to
developing countries
consequently the initiative has not only
contributed to the reduction of Global
Food prices but also provided essential
support to those severely affected by
the war particularly in developing
countries
Japan commands the unwavering this
dedication of the security General Mr
Griffis and Miss Greenspan to upholding
the initiative's continuity and
integrity
we also extend our appreciation to the
government of turkey for their
diplomatic and operational assistance to
the initiative
in life with efforts to prevent further
deterioration of food crisis
Japan actively contributes to providing
emergency food assistance
and enhancing the resilience of the
International Community including
vulnerable member states and has so far
committed over 250 million US dollars of
assistance
it is truly regrettable that Russia
opposed to a 120-day automatic extension
of the initiative in March it is also
deeply concerning that since May the 1st
The JCC inspection rate has dropped
significantly indicating not only
Russia's unwillingness to facilitate
inspections and the movements of ships
but also the intention to suspend the
initiative the prospect of suspension is
alarming as it disregards the potential
catastrophic consequences for Global
Food Supplies
to avoid Global hanger and Tackle food
insecurity we must ensure the safe and
smooth passage of vessels transporting
grains related to foodstuffs and
fertilizers from designated Ukrainian
ports by sustaining the initiative's
operations Japan calls on all relevant
parties particularly Russia to act
responsibly to ensure the continuation
of the initiative
Madam president the anguished endured
the anguish endured by Ukraine and the
subsequent strain on Global Food
security must cease Japan reaffirms its
unwavering dedication to providing
comprehensive support and standing in
solidarity with the people Ukraine
we pledge to continue our endeavors to
secure Global Food Supplies thereby
contributing to stabilizing Global
markets preventing poverty containing
social instability and maintenance of
International Peace and security I thank
you
representative
Humanity
situations
the conditions
foreign
negotiations
the last results
modern President we are grateful to you
as well as France and Ecuador for
convening this meeting
we are also grateful to USG Martin
Griffiths for his informative briefing
it is regrettable that the war on
Ukraine is continuing in a manner that
puts such risk the lives of innocent
civilians are several cities and towns
continue to come under the heavy
bombardment of military artillery
for several weeks intense fighting has
held in areas such as bakmut maripo
Nations for partner and savior Donetsk
where there are reports of numerous
civilian casualties
only in the first week of this month
ohchr recorded 221 civilian casualties
with 58 persons killed and 163 injured
mostly by explosive weapons of wide area
effects
as is often indicated in the briefings
to the council these numbers are likely
to be higher than those reported
while the casualties have reduced in
comparison to previous months we feel
strongly that any civilian casualty is
one too many for a war that ought not to
have been fought at all
moreover both sides have suffered great
course as hundreds of thousands of their
men are reported to have lost their
lives or been injured at the front lines
of the battle
while the turn of the war in coming days
is uncertain what remains unchanged are
the obligations of the warring parties
under International humanitarian law and
human rights laws to ensure the
protection of civilians from harm during
times of War
in keeping with these humanitarian
obligations we urge the parties to
ensure the safe passage of civilians and
Grant unhind and humanitarian access to
all areas where people require
assistance including the occupied
territories of Ukraine
we caution against deliberate attacks on
civilian populated areas as well as the
destruction of Civilian infrastructure
especially energy and water
installations homes medical centers
schools and marketplaces whose
destruction heightened the
vulnerabilities of civilians and worsen
their difficult circumstances
we are grateful for the continuing
commitment of the United Nations
humanitarian agencies and other partners
for Via indispensable efforts
implicating the impact of the war on
innocent lives we wish to emphasize the
importance of making medical
reproductive and psychological Health
Services accessible to all especially
for the women and children
we found the leadership of the United
Nations and turkey for their efforts in
support of the Black Sea grain
initiative and join the course that it's
further renewal would be helpful in a
surgeon Market commodity concerns as
indicated in today's briefing the grain
deal has been an important stabilizing
factor in global food prices over the
past year
in expressing Our Hope for an extension
of the initiative we really treat our
call on the parties and all stakeholders
to renew their commitments to ensure its
effective operation in all aspects
my delegation further urges relevant
stakeholders to make progress in
addressing any obstructions to the
effective implementation of the mou on
promoting Russian food exports and
fertilizers to World Markets
following the recent evacuation of
settlements around the separation
nuclear power plant an action that has
heightened uncertainty among residents
and also abroad we share in the concerns
raised about the Staffing conditions at
the plant and express our support for
the ongoing consultations led by the
iaea to secure the protection of the
power plant we wish to retreat the
absolute necessity of nuclear Safety and
Security in Ukraine and further
reiterates that there can be no winners
in a nuclearized conflict we therefore
appeal for such capabilities not to be
postured in the course of the conflict
in the interest of all Humanity
but unprecedent we remain Resolute in
our view that the war on Ukraine cannot
be worn militarily and that is why we
continue to urge the International
Community to keep at the Forefront of
its efforts diplomatic interventions
that can help to secure the immediate
succession of hostilities we believe
that it is already past time for the
International Community to have built on
the international consensus for peace in
Ukraine in working towards a credible
pathway for a comprehensive political
settlement in keeping with international
law and the spirits of the charter of
the United Nations
we once again call on the Russian
Federation to rethink its actions in
line with our shared commitments for
International Peace and security and to
immediately and unconditionally withdraw
its troops from the internationally
recognized borders of Ukraine in closing
I wish to be a trade Ghana's complete
commitment to the sovereignty political
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Ukraine as we renew our support for
all International humanitarian efforts
in Aid of the suffering people of
Ukraine I thank you
Martin Griffiths for his detail briefing
on the humanitarian situation in Ukraine
and on the Black Sea grain initiative
we regretted the pursuit of military
solution to the conflict continues to
take an iterable toll in the human lives
like in the airstrikes early this month
in Kiev and other Ukrainian cities and
the increased fighting back mode lasted
just last week to express our solidarity
to with the victims
we re-read our call on all parts to
respect and sure to respect to military
international law
and the fundamental principles of
distinction between combatants and
civilians of proportionality precaution
necessity and Humanity parties must
refrain from attacking critical civilian
infrastructure
we also emphasize the need foreign
humanitarian access to those in need
wherever they may be
and to ensure safe conditions for
humanitarian Personnel including medical
units and equipment
there must be no politicization of
humanitarian message nor select
selective application of international
humanitarian law
since the start of the conflict Brazil
has defended alongside with other member
states the immediate cessation of
hostilities without prejudging the
results of peaceful of future peace
negotiations in order to avoid further
violence
that remains our position
efforts of other member states in this
direction are encouraging we take note
of new appeals in favor of dialogue
between the parties which in our view is
the only path towards sustainable peace
we see the renewal of the Black Sea
grain initiative as a key step towards
building trust between the parties
Brazil encourages the extension of the
agreements for as long as necessary in
order to limit the uncertainties about
the global supply of grains and
fertilizers developing countries
dramatically suffered the side effects
of the conflict due to their structural
vulnerabilities to fluctuations in
prices of food and agricultural inputs
the success of the initiative is a
collective responsibility we encourage
Russian Ukraine to reach an
understanding and urge other members
from member states to avoid the actions
that go against the spirit of stumble
agreements including with regard to
Russian exports or grains and
fertilizers
modern present
we're concerned with the deterioration
of the political environment in the
council we around this table have
different perspectives on the complex
Origins and on the way forward but our
understanding of basic international
monetarian law norms and principles must
be shared nevertheless
Brazil cannot avoid but expressing
frustration with the console's inability
to find a common ground and improving a
resolution calling all parties to
respect International humanitarian law
we also find it regrettable that the
conflict in Ukraine contaminates other
issues on the international agenda
including another multilateral forum by
blocking dialogue and making it
difficult to find answers to other
urgent challenges for which we are
responsible
equally regrettable are attempts
mentioned in a meeting early this month
by the representative of Gabon to force
others to choose sides
defending the U.N Charter and
international law is the duty of all
members and we support the territorial
of the territory Integrity of Ukraine
however this principled position should
not hamper the work of the council as a
whole towards a peaceful solution
that will require that parties and other
member states to be willing to
understand the demands and concerns of
all sides the sooner we engage in this
Collective effort the better thank you
representative
of the United States
thank you madam president
thank you under Secretary General
Griffiths for your sobering remarks
first let me underscore that every day
Russia obstructs and threatens to
suspend the Black Sea grain initiative
Russia raises Global food prices around
the world
this means higher prices for everyone
poor and middle-income countries and the
U.N which also procures food on the
global market
we heard the UN say many times as we
heard from under Secretary General
Griffiths just now
that the initiative is critical to
stabilizing Global food prices and
getting food to the world's hungry
despite this Russia has stopped
discharging its commitments to the
United Nations and turkey
Russia has deliberately slowed the pace
of vessel inspections and severely
reduce the amount of grain leaving
Ukraine's ports to help meet the needs
of the world's most vulnerable
in recent weeks on more than one
occasion
the Russian federation's delegation at
the Joint coordination Center in
Istanbul has refused to allow any
inspection of ships
now Russia is threatening to end its
cooperation on May 18th
and while Russia keeps Ukrainian grain
supplies from feeding the hungry Russia
is successfully exporting its own bumper
crop of grain
the Russian government regularly cites
the need to implement its mou with the
UN
the export of Russian food and
fertilizers
in that very mou Russia committed to
quote facilitate the unimpeded export of
food sunflower oil and fertilizers
unquote
from Ukraine's Black Sea ports
Russia must Implement its own commitment
Russia must stop holding Global Food
security Hostage to its cynical power
plays and profit-taking
while we are all paying the increased
price for Russia's actions no one is
paying more dearly than Ukraine
after 15 months and countless briefings
unfortunately we are no closer to ending
the humanitarian suffering caused by
Russia's unprovoked war against Ukraine
instead
the death toll rises from Russia's
missile and drone strikes on Ukraine's
civilian population centers
from May 1 through 4
Russia launched more than 145 airstrikes
across Ukraine
that translates into an average of more
than one missile drone or bomb every
hour
24 hours a day three days straight
in just those three days alone
Russia's attacks have killed and injured
more than 100 civilians including at
least five children
organizations have reported worsening
conditions in the front line areas
and Necessities such as electricity food
and fuel are in short supply
President Putin's escalating attacks on
Ukraine's critical infrastructure
threaten us all
Russia's obstruction of the Black Sea
grain initiative impacts the world's
hungry
Russia has no interest in mitigating the
spillover effects of its war against
Ukraine just as Russia has shown no
genuine interest in negotiation or
meaningful diplomacy
we call on Putin to stop holding the
world's hungry hostage and extend and
fully implement the Black Sea grain
initiative
we again call on Russia to end its
attacks on the people of Ukraine and
withdraw its forces from Ukraine's
territory completely
Russia alone has the power to end the
war
it senselessly started
thank you madam president
representative
thank you president and I thank USG
Griffith for a sobering briefing and for
the work that he and his team are
carrying out on the ground
the humanitarian situation in Ukraine
has continued to deteriorate since the
last time discussed by this Council
over the past 15 months the number of
people in need of emergency humanitarian
Aid and protection has increased from
approximately 3 million to nearly 18
million
we states with all the clarity we can
master that this is only the result of
Russia's unprovoked aggression against
Ukraine
Malta strongly condemns Russia's
continued escalation of his illegal war
of aggression against Ukraine
ukrainians continue to suffer deliberate
large-scale's attacks on critical
infrastructure that is independent
indispensable for the survival of the
civilian population and have had their
basic services including Energy Water
Supply and heating destroyed by Russian
attacks
continuing attacks on energy
infrastructure prompted an energy crisis
in the first months of 2023 putting the
country's resilience further to the
tests
Russia has perpetrated indiscriminate
killings of civilians torture and other
forms of cruel inhumane and degrading
treatment sexual and gender-based
violence and abductions and forcible
deportations of children in doing so it
has willfully violated the rules-based
international order
president according to the recent report
by the International International
Commission of inquiry on Ukraine the
force transfers and deportation of
Ukrainian children to Russia or regions
under Russian control are violations of
international humanitarian law and the
amount of war crimes
these children must be promptly returned
to Ukraine using technical assistance
from International organizations
we demand that Russia stops these
unlawful deportations and comply with
the convention on the rights of the
child
we also welcome and encourage further
efforts to ensure full accountability
for all crimes committed by Russia
against Ukraine and on Ukraine's
territory
in light of this we are supportive of
the ongoing icj and ICC processes
Malta strongly believes that there can
be no peace without Justice in this
regard Malta joined other state parties
of the ICC in making a referral to the
court on the situation in Ukraine and
will continue its efforts to strengthen
the cooperation between the ICC and the
security Council to keep investigating
the Russian crime of aggression
Malta is a strong supporter of the ICC
as a beacon of accountability we take
note of the warrant issued against
president President Vladimir Putin and
the Russian commissioner for children's
rights Mariel Volva belova we are
firming our belief that crimes committed
must not go unpunished and that all
perpetrators must be held accountable
Malta will continue to support all
efforts to address the humanitarian
consequences of Russia's aggression we
also reiterate that the only step
towards a just and Lasting peace would
be for Russia to immediately seize all
hostilities and unconditionally
completely withdraw all of its forces
and military equipment from the entire
territory of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
I conclude by highlighting the
importance of the Black Sea grain
initiative which extends Beyond Ukraine
and affects Global Food security
it is Paramount that the agreement is
further extended between all parties to
alleviate pressures on security of
Supply affecting communities throughout
the world
this is yet another element that needs
to be pursued as part of the collective
efforts to secure sustainable and
Lasting peace thank you
of China
[Music]
the International Community should take
positive steps to mitigate the
humanitarian consequences of the
conflict and make joint efforts for the
de-escalation of the situation and an
early cessation of hostilities
[Music]
that must be observed in situations of
conflict parties to the conflict should
spare no effort in protecting the safety
of civilians and civilian facilities
women and children are the most
vulnerable groups in armed conflicts and
must be given special attention we
welcome the expansion of Aid to all
affected populations and the
facilitation of repair and restoration
of Civilian infrastructure by the
International Community including
humanitarian agencies on the basis of
neutrality and impartiality
the balanced for and effective
implementation of the Black Sea great
initiative and the mou on the export of
Russian food and fertilizers and
supports the UN and playing an important
role in this regard to remove the real
obstacles facing the export of Russian
food and fertilizers
a crucial role in safeguarding the
Safety and Security of Civilian nuclear
facilities
response measures should be taken
seriously and managed the world economy
is faced with renewable risks of
recession which calls for the
coordinated actions by all countries to
jointly keep Global food energy and
financial markets
however
one round of unilateral sanctions after
another ever expanding long-armed
jurisdiction
to severe humanitarian consequences but
also undermined the global industrial
and Supply chains
the U.S and other relevant countries
should seriously reflect upon their
behavior immediately men their ways and
create conditions for developing
countries to grow their economies and
improve livelihoods they must refrain
from engaging in economic coercion on
one hand
and are drawing the aversion and
opposition from a growing number of
countries
must be pointed out that the so-called
rules-based International order
is likewise highly problematically sense
they are no excuse for the Us and other
relevant countries use unilateral
sanctions and hardly enjoy broad support
or recognition from the International
Community
and most fundamentally
the greatest sense of urgency is needed
for the political sediment of the crisis
there are no simple answers to complex
issues any comprehensive Solutions
always begins with the first step
and the presumption of dialogue and
negotiation cannot wait in
all parties should create conditions for
advancing dialogue and negotiation
instead of adding fuel to the fire and
escalating tensions in an attempt to
profit from it and the Ukraine issue
China has always been on the side of the
keys and everything we do is for the
promotion of Photography
special Representatives the Chinese
government on Eurasian Affairs has left
today
visits to Ukraine Poland France Germany
and Russia
of the Ukraine crisis thank you madam
president
of the United Kingdom
thank you president and I join others in
thanking under Secretary General
Griffiths for his briefing and work on
the ground
and your briefing today under Secretary
General reminds us of the enormous cost
of Russia's war of aggression
Russia has continued to conduct massive
missile and UAV strikes against
inhabited areas across Ukraine killing
innocent civilians
the UK is appalled by reports of recent
Russian attacks on the Ukrainian Red
Cross warehouses in Odessa and on a
mobile Hospital in mikalayev
there is no excuse for attacking the
most vulnerable or the brave
humanitarian workers who are supporting
them
so we call on Russia to abide by
International humanitarian law
in particular to observe the distinction
between combatants and civilians
Ukrainian civilians indeed all civilians
should be protected by all combatants
similarly Aid organizations and Aid
workers whose mission is to help
innocent civilians in humanitarian need
are not a Target
in russian-occupied areas of Ukraine an
estimated 4 million people are living in
dire forlorn conditions
despite regular attempts by the UN to
gain access to deliver humanitarian
support
Russia has never provided the necessary
security guarantees for access
we continue to call for unimpeded and
sustained humanitarian access to the
people of Ukraine
we call on Russia to stop denying access
and cease its attacks on critical
infrastructure and residential areas
president as we've heard from others
the bsgi is critically important
over 30 million tons of grain and other
foodstuffs have been exported under the
initiative since the 1st of August
the deal has been critical to lowering
Global food prices and getting urgently
needed grain to countries that need it
most
as the world food program has said
grain deliveries to any country Drive
Global prices down
so we urge Russia to stop threatening to
leave the initiative
and instead to agree to a sustained and
stable deal
in the meantime Russia continues to
block and delay ship inspections
this obstruction harms Global Food
security by delaying shipments
restricting supplies and keeping prices
high for food importing countries
finally president the UK is fully
committed to holding Russia to account
for its illegal actions in Ukraine
we will continue to support independent
investigations into the atrocities
committed in Ukraine as part of a just
and sustained piece
thank you
Madam president I would like to join
others in thanking under Secretary
General Griffiths for his informative
briefing today Mr Griffith's your
sobering report is not only a reminder
of the importance of why we are here but
what we must do are utmost to avoid
losing our sense of urgency surrounding
this conflict neither should we stand
idly by as this war transforms into a
protracted conflict of several years the
consequences are too grave for all of us
yet fighting has been continuous and
unending with the price being paid by
civilians who bear the brunt of the
suffering the scale of Devastation and
the dire humanitarian situation in
Ukraine cannot be truly conveyed in the
numbers we have heard today
in the past 14 months of War there have
been over 23 000 verified civilian
casualties and the actual figure is
likely to be considerably higher 18
million people are in need of
humanitarian assistance more than 8
million people are refugees across
Europe and an additional 5 million
people have been displaced inside
Ukraine
humanitarian access must therefore be
insured in order to allow much needed
Aid to reach civilians caught in the
fighting
in recent weeks there has been a
noticeable uptick of missile and drone
strikes that have damaged or destroyed
civilian infrastructure humanitarian
facilities have been hit last week a
Ukrainian Red Cross warehouse and mobile
Health Clinic were destroyed we once
again reiterate our call on the parties
to the conflict to abide by their
obligations under International
humanitarian law civilian objects must
never be the target of an attack
the UAE continues to provide
humanitarian assistance to those
impacted by the conflict including a
donation of ambulances recently we also
continue to support civilian energy
needs we have sent 2500 generators and
are sending additional energy efficient
power supplies in the coming period
Madam president the war in Ukraine has
had far-reaching consequences beyond the
battlefield as the Ripple effects have
exacerbated Global Food crises the Black
Sea grain initiative has proven vital
against this backdrop the world has seen
the safe export of over 30 million
metric tons of grain and foodstuffs from
Ukraine since the beginning of the
initiative
these efforts thus far have successfully
contributed to alleviating the mounting
pressure on global food prices and the
inevitable knock-on effects of a
destabilized food system on the world's
poorest
we are encouraged that this vital
initiative continues and commend the
earnest efforts of the United Nations
and turkey to bring all parties to the
table in order to find Solutions on the
outstanding issues and we're pleased to
hear that the UN will continue to work
closely with all sides to ensure the
smooth operation of the bsgi at the same
time we continue to call for the full
implementation of the mou on Russian
fertilizers and food products and
continue to support efforts to this end
while the importance of the Black Sea
grain initiative is widely appreciated
for its practical benefits in reality it
is also we hope a trust building
mechanism reaching an agreement again on
this initiative and other successful
negotiated outcomes such as exchanges of
prisoners of War demonstrate that there
remains some degree of willingness to
negotiate a pathway forward we are
cautiously hopeful that such efforts can
be a conduit for building trust between
all parties and may serve to remind all
parties of the benefits of Peace Madam
president the UAE has consistently held
that there is no viable military
solution to this war and we will not
waver in this belief we call for
de-escalation diplomacy and dialogue as
the way forward the International
Community should rally behind all
efforts that lead to the cessation of
hostilities and pave the way for a just
and Lasting peace one that respects
Ukraine's sovereignty Independence and
territorial Integrity thank foreign
at the same time accountability is an
imperative
foreign
[Music]
applications
the president
thank you madam president distinguished
members of the security Council under
Secretary General Griffiths
I also recognize the representative of
Putin's regime in the permanent seat of
the Soviet Union
we need to address the Russian war
against my country
after one of the lowest periods in the
history of this Council
the April presidency of the aggressive
state
which inflicted yet another blow
on an already compromised principal body
of the United Nations
this April alone the Russian occupiers
committed
6139 war crimes
these crimes led to the death of 207
Ukrainian civilians including 11
children
on the 28th of April Russia again
launched a missile strike
when a multi-story apartment building
this time in human chirkasi region
as a result 23 residents were killed
including six children
so much about Putin send voice saying
that they do not attack the Ukrainian
civilians
many of you have seen the heartbreaking
video footage from umen
where people desperately waited for
hours near the rubble for their loved
ones to be retrieved
in Russia the TV audience watched this
footage on the stage propaganda Channel
Russia won
meanwhile the Russian Ministry of War
posted on social media
right on target
indeed
since day one of the Russian invasion
regardless of the torrent of lies from
the Russia's representative in the
council
innocent civilians have been a
deliberate Target for Russian weapons
and the permitted object for Russian
crimes
racism and East disciples
including in this chamber
have defied logic
all laws of non-contradiction
in all semblance of decency
two days later on the 1st of May another
Ukrainian child a 14 year old boy was
killed in the village of lesunivka
Journey region by a Russian Airborne
that also destroyed the local school
this attack was another case of the
cowardly and Despicable Terror tactics
that the Russian's army applies widely
against the northern Ukrainian regions
liberated a year ago
air bombing of Ukrainian border
settlements from Russian airspace
just like any other terrorist the
Russia's servicemen do not care where
these bombs finally fall the main thing
is that they must show death and
destruction
Terror against the liberated areas has
become a Hallmark of the Russia's Army
on the 3rd of May in Harrison region
alone Russia killed 23 people 49 were
wounded
in a store railway station gas station
their homes
on the 7th of May a Russia's missile
strike damaged the Mobile hospital in
Michelob region which also belonged to
the Red Cross of Ukraine
since the beginning of the full-fledged
Russia's Invasion 25 facilities of the
Red Cross to Ukraine have been damaged
or destroyed
on the 9th of May a massive barrage of
25 missiles slammed into the Ukrainian
cities
the day before on the 8th of May
Ukrainian Air Force were able to down
all 35 Iranian drones launched by Russia
also on the 8th of May Russian missiles
completely destroyed a war house
of the Red Cross of Ukraine in Odessa
with all the humanitarian Aid there
one employee was killed
as a result of the attack adjusts a
branch of the Red Cross through Ukraine
was compelled to suspend the provision
of humanitarian Aid and the
implementation of a number of
humanitarian projects
we are grateful to our friends and
allies who literally saved the lives of
ukrainians by helping us to reinforce
our AF air defense
this enabled us to shoot down 23 out of
25 missiles
yet more needs to be done to fully
protect our skies and civilians
this weekend ukrainians also had to
spend their time with air raid sirens
sounding in the background as Russia
launched massive new attack attacks
using dozens of Iranian drones cruise
missiles and s-300 Rockets
the cities of humanitsuke their Noble
Nikolai harkib and constantinuka
indonesk region suffered him human
casualties and serious damage to
civilian infrastructure
colleagues in addition to the immediate
harm caused to millions of ukrainians by
the Russian war the long-term effects of
displacement trauma and poverty will be
felt for years to come
the most vulnerable Safa the most
Russia is violating the fundamental
principles of child protection in
Wartime
as a result of the Russia's aggression
480 children have been killed and 967
injured
to date 13 cases of sexual violence
against children have been verified by
the office of prosecutor general of
Ukraine
indoneskiev her son Michael live and
journey region
the real numbers are definitely higher
and our law enforcement continues the
investigation
Russia's attacks have damaged
3185 educational institutions
or which 330 were destroyed
in total
1412 Healthcare objects and 577
Healthcare facilities have been damaged
or reached 258 facilities were destroyed
according to UNICEF country team report
education for an estimated 5.7 million
children has been disrupted
one and a half million children face
mental health issues
the forceful deportation of children is
nothing but a well-planned Kremlin
policy aimed at aggressive
indoctrination ethnic identification
change and the deprivation of Ukraine of
its future generation
to date the Ukrainian authorities have
identified
19393 children deported or abducted to
the Russian Federation or to the
territories of Ukraine temporarily
occupied by Russia
nearly 4 390 of them are orphans or
children without parental care
it has been possible to return only
364 children
we know it was concerned that Russia has
reportedly intensified his deportation
and abduction practices in the occupied
territories under the guise of so-called
evacuation
like many of you in this console we
reiterate that it is only that Russia's
troops that must be evacuated from the
territory of Ukraine as soon as this
happens the atrocities of War will be
over
we welcome the well-founded conclusions
of the reports by the commission on
inquiry on Ukraine established by the
Human Rights Council and by the oec
Moscow mechanism that have reconfirmed
the enormous scale of violations and
crimes committed by the Russia's
occupiers
in particular against children
we call on the Secretary General and the
special representative on children and
armed conflict to give a proper
assessment of the gravity or violations
against children in Ukraine by the
Russia's government forces in the
upcoming annual report
we believe that this report should
contribute to ensuring accountability
for perpetrators and justice for
Ukrainian children
victims of the Russian aggression
the invasion of the Soviet permanent
seat in the security Council should give
neither immunity nor amnesty to war
criminals
Madam President we have already brought
to the council's attention to the
critical situation with mine
contamination of Ukrainian lands
according to preliminary estimates
170 180 000 square kilometers of
Ukrainian territory are contaminated
with mines and other explosive ordinance
our primary task today is to accelerate
the demining process as much as possible
increase the number of demanding teams
and equip them with special equipment
unfortunately those people who risk
their lives to clear Ukrainian territory
from mines and restore safety for people
are also a target for the Russia's
troops
most recently on the 7th of May in her
zone region nine members of a demining
team were killed by Russian shells while
on duty
the mine contamination in Ukraine is an
issue for Global Food security as more
than 4 700 square kilometers
of contaminated areas are agricultural
lands
in such extraordinary circumstances
Ukraine continues to act as a reliable
contributor to Global Food security by
implementing ease agreement with the
United Nations under the Black Sea grain
initiative and advocating for expanding
is its geographical scope by including
new Ukrainian Foods
as of the beginning of May Ukraine
exported 29.8 million tons of grain and
foodstuffs
this number includes includes 600 000
tons of grain shipped by vessels
chartered by the world food program in
support of its humanitarian operations
in Afghanistan Ethiopia Kenya Somalia
and Yemen
this volume could have been
significantly higher if Russia did not
resort to impeding practices
we are concerned that since the 1st of
May the inspection rate has dropped to
an average of 2.9
inspections per day compared to 6.6 in
the period of August 2022 April 2023
as a result in April we were able to
expose through the grain Corridor Less
Than 3 million tones
which is only a half of our agricultural
expert capacities
together with the United Nations and
turkey Ukraine strives for the extension
of the initiative without any delay and
disruption to shipments
according to experts if it is blocked by
Russia the global food prices could
increase substantially again
these dream perspective should should be
taken seriously
it is disgusting that Russia still
pretends to be on the losing side of the
deal
I will not even remind the Council of
the immorality of Sajak complaints from
the aggressive state which has been and
Remains the only threat to food
shipments in the Black Sea
let us just turn to the data that
clearly shows the benefits for Russia
from the deal
the data indicates that Russian lead
expert in January February 2023 nearly
doubled from the same period a year
earlier
we therefore consider the speculations
to be an attempt to whitewash Russian
deliberate practices to weaponize Food
Supplies and urge the International
Community to give a Resolute response
let me remind
where some statements here
Black Sea grain initiative is not due to
expire this week
it is however the Russian blackmail
deadline that expires this week
Madam president a week ago we paid
tribute to the victims and heroes of the
second World War
marking the end of this war in Europe
the atrocities of this war prompted our
predecessors to commit themselves to
save succeeding Generations from this
college of War
now in Ukraine Russia reminds us that
our commemoration slogan never again is
still a goal to be achieved
the lessons of the second world war
teach us that just
and Lasting peace can only be possible
if evil is defeated
and is not able to continue its
aggression
any attempt to appease the aggressor at
the expanse of its victims will only
protract and broaden the scope of the
tragedy
as my president said on the 8th of May
when Ukraine along with the entire world
commemorated the victory over Nazism
we in Ukraine give meaning to these
votes never again
not only to remember but also to protect
not only to Value life but also to do
the utmost to ensure that everyone who
threatens life everyone who brings
aggression
everyone who resolves to Terror against
other nations
every such evil loses
Ukraine has committed to stop this
modern evil of racism
we are Guided by the Supreme principle
of morality that is the categorical
imperative since it is not conditional
upon one's preferences I thank you
to the United Nations thank you very
much Madam president I have the honor to
speak on behalf of the European Union
and its member states the candidate
country is North Macedonia Montenegro
Albania Ukraine the Republic of Moldova
and Bosnia has a governor the potential
candidate country Georgia and the after
country Lichtenstein member of the
European economic area as well as
Andorra and Monaco all align themselves
with this statement and I want to like
everyone else first thank very much on
the Secretary General Martin Griffiths
for the briefing and also of course to
commend you and the UN system for the
excellent work that you are doing on the
ground providing humanistic human turn
assistance under very difficult
circumstances in Ukraine and in many
other places
the horrors that you Mr Griffis and and
other have described from inside Ukraine
resulting from Russia's unprovoked and
unjustified military aggression are
unimaginable
for 15 months now the Russian leadership
has struggled without success to find
any justification whatsoever for its
illegal war of aggression Russia must
stop its war and immediately completely
and unconditionally withdraw all of its
forces and proxies from the entire
territory of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
Madam president
I will emphasize three points in my
intervention first the importance of
upholding international law and
international humanitarian law second
the need for accountability and third
efforts to address the global
consequences of Russia's war of
aggression
first international law and
International in return law must be
respected therefore Russia must
immediately stop its indiscriminate and
decimating shelling of civilians and
civilian areas under International Human
return law deliberate attacks on
civilians or attacks that do not
distinguish between military targets and
civilians are prohibited under all
circumstances
we strongly condemn cases related to
sexual and gender-based violence we are
particularly horrified by the impact of
Russians aggressions on children
children have been killed and maimed
schools and hospitals have been tacked
in blatant violation of international
law Russia's practice of forcibly
transferring and deporting Ukrainian
children is a violation of international
humanitarian law the U.N Commission of
inquiry on Ukraine concluded that it
amounts to war crimes Russia must
immediately facilitate the safe return
of ukrainians who were forcibly
transferred or deported
we also strongly condemn Russia's
attacks and violate violence against
journalists and media workers UNESCO has
stated that 12 journalists were killed
in Ukraine since the start of the
invasion journalist safety is
indispensable to ensuring the right to
freedom of opinion and expression any
particular the freedom of the press
we urge Russia to enable safe rapid and
unhindered humanitarian access to
populations in need of assistance in
particular into the temporarily occupied
territories through the front lines
it is imperative that the safety of
humanitarian workers is insured
second
there can be no impunity for the
commanders perpetrators and accomplices
of atrocities the EU is firmly committed
to ensuring full accountability for war
crimes and the other most serious crimes
committed in connection with Russia's
war of aggression against Ukraine
including through the establishment of
an appropriate mechanism for the
prosecution of the crime of aggression
we welcome the creation of the new
international center for prosecution of
the crime of aggression against Ukraine
in The Hague and we reiterate our
support for the investigations of the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court
we're also fully supportive of the
establishment of an international
mechanism to register the damages Russia
has inflicted as recommended by the U.N
general assembly in its resolutions of
November 2022
third Madam president Russia's
aggression and his weaponization of food
have undermined Global Food security
driving up food and fertilizer prices
worldwide we welcome the sector
journal's active engagement to address
these serious consequences and we call
on all member states to come together in
support of his efforts they benefit us
all including Russia
the Black Sea grain initiative in
particular has been instrumental in
bringing down Global food prices it is
crucial that is renewed and runs at its
full potential to provide continuity and
predictability needed by operators and
to avoid a discontinuation in shipments
to grains to countries in need we must
not forget that there would be no need
for this initiative if it were not for
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
in addition to the Black Sea initiative
the eu's solidarity Lanes have allowed
the export of more than 32 million tons
of Ukraine's food and agricultural Goods
world food program chartered vessels
have transported almost 600 000 tons of
wheat through various Black Sea ports
including to Ethiopia Afghanistan Yemen
Somalia and Kenya through Ukraine's own
grain from Ukraine program hundreds and
thousands of metric tons of grain have
been donated to countries in need as we
just heard we know these efforts are
still insufficient for countries
vulnerable to food insecurity therefore
together with our member states we are
providing 18 billion euros to address
urgent and longer term food security
needs in
2021-2024 focusing on regions most
affected by food insecurity concretely
this support enables vulnerable
countries to afford key Staples Imports
despite price increases and currency
devaluations as well as to increase
their resilience and food autonomy in
the longer term
I want to reassure the members of this
Council that every effort in support of
Ukraine has come in addition to and not
instead of our Global commitments as
illustrated by the increase in EU
official development assistance we're
grateful to all countries who are
generously supporting those in need in
Ukraine and elsewhere and once again
encourage all to step up their
assistance in line with ochas
humanitarian response plan and appeal
for aid for this year
Madam president in closing I reiterate a
call for just comprehensive and Lasting
peace in line with the U.N Charter and
the general assembly resolution adopted
in February the EU is unwavering in our
support to Ukraine's Independence
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
within its International recognized
borders and its inherent right of
self-defense against Russia's aggression
we will continue to stand verbally with
the Ukrainian people for as long as it
takes I thank you very much
I also want to thank Ecuador and France
for requesting this meeting and thank
you for convening it I also want to
appreciate the opportunity that we are
provided to address to address the
council in addition to the points made
by the Ambassador I would like to add
several points and under Secretary
General Griffith provided a sober
overview of the humanitarian situation
in Ukraine I want to take the
opportunity to thank indeed to pay
tribute to the efforts of the under
Secretary General and his team to
address the multiple challenges provided
by by this aggression sadly the
civilians are still the ones that pay
the price of the illegal aggression of
Russia and Ukraine this is day number
446 since the aggression International
and international Humanity in
humanitarian law must be respected and
this is a red line agreed by the entire
U.N membership and yet the new barrage
of rockets towards Ukraine provides no
indication that Russia has any intention
to stop its indiscriminate shelling of
civilians and civilian areas
ironically next week we are to celebrate
the U.N the week of protection of
civilians
the ruins of urban and rural areas are
in sharp contrast and pay for in sharp
and painful contrast with sdg 11 are
sustainable cities and communities there
could be no more direct connection
between development security than this
one
later this year we are expected to take
stock of the agenda 2030.
at The sdg Summit in September
the Russian invasion and the continuing
aggression towards Ukraine also hamper
our efforts towards the 2030 agenda in
addition to the blatant violation of the
principles of international law and
international humanitarian law
Madam president since the beginning of
the year the International Community has
sent strong messages regarding the
predictability of accessing food around
the globe via the Black Sea Green
initiative
we welcome the continued efforts
undertaking by the Secretary General by
under Secretary General Griffith and
under secretary response and those of
turkey in keeping bsgi alive
we need this initiative to move forward
we need predictability
we need responsibility
we are too far implementing bsgi to go
back and with aggravated Global food
crisis there is no time for secular
thoughts as we heard it today there
should be no plan B to bsgi
on his part Romania will continue to
rise to the expectations and facilitate
the exports of grains from Ukraine to
reach those in need
solidarity lanes and so far over 16
million tons of grains across the
Romanian territory mainly through
Romanian Black Sea Black Sea ports in
addition to the amounts already used
through the bsgi
Madam president
in line with the resolution adopted by
the general assembly on the 23rd of
February this year Romania will continue
to call for a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine
likewise we should also be mindful of
the danger of impunity of those
responsible of crimes committed in
connection with Russia's word of
aggression against Ukraine
alongside the Russians that undertake
abuses and violation of Human Rights and
international humanitarian law
provisions
the March report of the independent
International Commission of inquiry and
Ukraine recommends to the Russian
Federation to limit the use of private
military and security companies as they
are code generally less accountable than
regular forces and code
Romania firmly believes that Justice
must be done with regard to all core
crimes Committee in the context of this
war all called crimes including the
crime of aggression while this is not an
easy path we should rise to this
challenge task a challenging task rather
than be discouraging thank you madam
president
Poland
Poland appreciates the convening of this
time being very needed meeting
we value the opportunity to contribute
to the discussion triggered once again
by the new distressful facts regarding
the humanitarian impact of the Russian
aggression against Ukraine which we
heard about from the our well-informed
briefer and I would like to thank USG
Martin Griffiths for his briefing
excellencies let me concentrate today on
the following three points
firstly Russia has been waging its war
of aggression against Ukraine and
Ukrainian people for close to 500 days
now
and is human and material
tolls keep growing with every one of
them
as the Russian military fails on the
Battleground it tries to compensate for
its shortcoming comings there with
continuous brutal aggression against the
innocent civilians
I write Sirens keep blaring across the
whole Ukraine
critical infrastructure facilities
Remain the primary targets of the
Russian Rockets
new civilian deaths are being
continuously reported
all this Bears the characteristic of a
total war
and as such requires repeated Universal
condemnation time and time again
my second Pond refers to the Russian
strategy here at the United Nations
despite the fact that the vast majority
of the U.N member states have been
crystal clear in their condemnation of
the Russian aggression and its
disastrous humanitarian impact on
numerous occasions
Russia keeps ignoring our Appeals
distorting the basic facts even today
and flooding us with this information
and propaganda about this special
military operation
their hope is to that the International
Community will eventually become tired
of with this war
that we keep stop that we will keep stop
talking that will stop talking about it
and that will eventually forget about it
appeal to you today is simple
let us never be indifferent
that does never get used to war to any
War even if it disappears from the
breaking news headlines
as long as the Ukrainian Ukraine's
ukrainians keep paying the highest price
heroically the defending each square
kilometer of its territory against the
invading forces we cannot let our
resolve falter
we need to stand our ground and continue
to defend the U.N Charter we need to
keep putting pressure on Russia to see
this aggression
when there is no aggression there is no
war so that's the way to achieve peace
the whole world looks forward to
finally we should keep helping Ukraine
on the ground as long as it takes in
2022 the total value of support from for
Ukraine from Poland amounted to about 10
billion US dollars
this year the expenditure only to cover
the social benefits and educational
needs of ukrainians most women and
children finding refuge in Poland will
amount to another 1.2 billion US dollars
in the face of the systematic systemic
Russian attacks aimed at destroying
energy and heating infrastructure during
this the past winter
other commentary and assistance focus on
spare parts and equipment for the energy
infrastructure as well as Transformers
and Power and aggregates
we will continue with our support for
Ukraine both here in the United Nations
and on the ground as long as it is
necessary
will not get worn down in our solidarity
with Ukraine by Russian hybrid attacks
on Poland which are upskirting recently
and we call up call upon all member
states to do the same thank you
president
I'm speaking on behalf of the Baltic
states Latvia Estonia and my own country
Lithuania we fully align ourselves with
the statement of the European Union
I also thank the under Secretary General
Martin Griffiths for his comprehensive
briefing
we highly value the work of the United
Nations in their efforts to provide
humanitarian Aid to people affected by
Russians and provoked and premeditated
were against Ukraine as well as in their
close monitoring and the coming
documentation of Human Rights abuses and
violations of international humanitarian
law
we also appreciate their active
engagement in the numerous diplomatic
efforts including the blog Black Sea
grain initiative
over the past 15 months Russia has
inflicted immense suffering upon Ukraine
and its people through its full scale
war of aggression against Ukraine
the humanitarian consequences of
Russia's attacks on the civilian
population have been devastating
each additional day of aggression
prolongs the toll of the human suffering
Russia responding to its military losses
in Ukraine is terrorizing the civilian
population by conducting massive missile
and UAV strikes at critical
infrastructure and residential areas
including GIF and Odessa these horrific
attacks which result in significant
casualties and destruction are designed
to erode the will of ordinary ukrainians
to resist
however launching attacks with the sole
purpose of terrorizing civilians is a
war crime
Madam president
the um and the OAC have published
extensive reports indicating atrocities
committed by Russia and its Armed Forces
against civilians in Ukraine these acts
have been classified as war crimes
crimes against humanity
and gross violations of the Geneva
conventions
we highlight the large-scale attempts by
Russia to abduct and transfer children
from Ukraine
International humanitarian law must be
helped collectively with International
organizations leading the way
the recent arrest warrants issued by the
international criminal court for
Russia's President Vladimir Putin and
presidential commissioner for children's
rights in Russia Maria below
The Oasis Moscow mechanism
of experts on the situation of Ukrainian
children
in the United Nations High commissioners
independent International Commission of
inquiry on Ukraine are all concrete
steps towards accountability and
safeguarding the international
humanitarian law
we strongly condemn Russia's attempt to
intimidate the ICC and undermine
International efforts to secure Justice
Madam president on May 8th Russia's
Russian strikes destroyed 1 000 square
meters of humanitarian Aid stored in the
large Warehouse or Ukrainian Red Cross
although Odessa region
by attacking agricultural infrastructure
and restricting Maritime experts Moscow
seeks to instrumentalize the
vulnerabilities of other countries
it is estimated that Ukrainian
agricultural products feed 400 million
people around the world
despite the full-blown war on its
territory Ukraine remains one of the
world's top five agricultural exporters
the Black Sea grain initiative the grain
from Ukraine and the EU solidarity lines
have played an instrumental role in this
by alleviating the global food crisis
severely exacerbated by Russia's illegal
War of the aggression
if Russia were serious about countering
food insecurity it stop its threat
unilaterally
black secret initiative
to delaying the inspection of wessels
the building states are making
significant diplomatic efforts to
support Ukraine providing humanitarian
economic and military aid to help
together with Poland we are among top
for bilateral Aid donors to Ukraine as a
percentage of our gdps
important to recall that all the support
being provided to Ukraine is an addition
to rather than at the expense of
Aid and development cooperation to other
countries around the world
Madam president Russia must realize that
it cannot win Ukraine ultimately it is
Ukraine that will prevail
with unwavering support from the
International Community Ukraine will
continue to demonstrate its remarkable
courage determination and moral
strengths at its fights to liberate his
homeland
a piece will be achieved when Ukraine's
sovereignty territorial integrity and
Independence are fully restored enabling
its people to thrive and prosper
we reiterate our support for president
zelenski's efforts to promote a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
line with the UN Charter and we support
the basic principles outlined in this
piece initiative
we are committed to upholding Buddhist
criminal regime accountable for the war
of aggression Unleashed against Ukraine
we the International Community must
unite and commit ourselves to ensure the
full accountability for the core
International crimes in connection with
Russia's war against Ukraine including
through the establishment of the special
International Tribunal for the
prosecution of a crimes aggression
the full version of the statement will
be provided to the members of the
security Council in written I thank you
madam president
Denmark thank you madam president I have
the honor to speak on behalf of the five
Nordic countries Finland Iceland Norway
Sweden and then of course my own country
Denmark
the nordics are committed to the
protection of civilians in armed
conflict as a Cornerstone of
international humanitarian law
globally and at the country level in
Africa the Middle East Asia the Americas
and Europe our commitment to
humanitarian action is resolute
I want to take this opportunity to thank
under Secretary General Griffiths for
his briefing
and for the work of Archer's staff along
with the staff of other U.N agencies and
other humanitarian actors who do
humanitarian work around the clock under
impossible conditions in Ukraine and
elsewhere
now for more than a year now Ukraine has
been bravely resisting a brutal war of
aggression initiated by Russia
the devastating consequences of the war
also reads Beyond Ukrainian borders to
the Horn of Africa Yemen and Beyond
where millions of people have been
pushed deeper into food insecurity due
to Rising food and energy prices across
the world
Russia's war against Ukraine has
compounded many Global challenges making
it an urgent matter of International
Peace and security and obviously a
matter of concern to all member states
Madam president
Russia's indiscriminate missile attacks
across Ukraine's Ukrainian cities
continue to cause harm to civilians and
severe damage to civilian property and
infrastructure illustrating Russia's
complete disregard for international
humanitarian law
the consequences of these brutal attacks
are extensive and far-reaching and the
situation is especially dire close to
the front lines with the need for
protection and humanitarian assistance
such as food medicines and shelter is
alarmingly high
for many the consequences of the war are
long-lasting damaging the very
foundation for recovery and healing both
at the personal and at the societal
level
in this regard the nordics welcomed the
establishment of a register of damage
documents and claims of damage caused by
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine as recommended by the U.N
general assembly in its resolutions ES
11-5
Madam president delivering humanitarian
assistance in Ukraine to those in need
is difficult and dangerous
the situation is a horrific reminder of
the need to ensure protection for all
civilians under International
humanitarian law civilians and civilian
objects must be protected on
humanitarian access must have full safe
and unhindered access and we condemn in
the strongest terms attacks on
humanitarian operations such as the
attacks on the Ukrainian Red Cross
Warehouse in Odessa and on medical
facilities in Miku live on 8th of May
and we call on Russia to allow full safe
and unhindered access for humanitarian
access
Madam president
further to the tragic consequences for
people in Ukraine Russia's illegal
Invasion has had catastrophic Global
effects the worsening food crisis and
the volatility of Global Food and energy
prices have impacted countries around
the world
the world food program estimates that an
astounding 345 million people will
experience acute food insecurity this
year
this is the equivalent of more than the
entire population of the United States
of America
the world's poorest and those in the
most vulnerable situations tend to be
the ones most affected by such crises
as a result the need for humanitarian
assistance globally has increased and at
the same time food assistance and
humanitarian operations have become more
expensive exacerbating the gap between
humanitarian needs and available funding
Madam president
until Russia ends its illegal war of
aggression against Ukraine the
continuation of the Black Sea grain
initiative remains imperative to avoid a
worsening of the global food crisis
up until earlier this month the
initiative had ensured the export of as
much as 30 million tons of grains and
foodstuff thereby helping to stabilize
Global food prices and allowing access
to food for Preble at risk of famine
we welcome the acts of Engagement by the
Secretary General and turkey and urge
Russia to ensure a long-term rollover of
the Black Sea grain initiative in line
with the Istanbul agreement and to
immediately suspend its military
operations
the extension and full implementation of
this initiative is critical in order to
avoid a further deterioration of the
global food crisis
Madam president let me conclude by
saying the nordics will continue to
stand with Ukraine and its people and we
commend Ukraine's Initiative for a just
peace and support the various
initiatives that are seeking
accountability for international crimes
committed in connection with Russia's
aggression against Ukraine I thank you
for their statement
s